the report during the Press was was Grand
so I was like which director is it where
he had this experience recently with
because I can't honestly you know not
to discuss it's definitely going to
sound this way it like it's hard to
not think is he talking about Tiger
Woods it is it just sounds like he is
[Music] ladies and gentlemen Chris Hemsworth has
slammed Taiko YTD and Marvel he's sick of their
virtue signaling the two woke the two works for me
now for me I want to give my hammer to a woman let
alone two women my hammer to a woman no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no guys I've been
hearing all these headlines and I was like well
let's Deep dive this is what we do we deconstruct
what our dramatic headlines and there you go is
this really dramatic this is as dramatic as they
want the clickbait to sound let's see what's going
on John how are you I am I'm really nice today how
are you sir I'm doing okay it's been a wild week
that if you follow my Instagram you'll know what's
going on but anyway guys leave a like that'd be
very much appreciated uh let's dive into this now
uh Chris Hemsworth he's been making the rounds uh
ever since his show Limitless has come out it's a
show where he uh takes a pill gives him access to
100 of his brain yeah he's been getting asked of
course about Thor because he's Christmas Hemsworth
and while there's a kind of a lot of quotes to go
from there's there's two main paragraphs that
I think are the important ones to sort of speak
on because it's led to okay it sounds like
Chris Hemsworth is done with I mean even in
my interpretations he's done with the goofy side
of Thor not necessarily he's done with the humor
because the humor's always been present with Thor
but maybe the goofier side and did he throw shade
at Taiko YTD that's how some people have been
interpreting it and that one I do want to kind
of dive into because it I could see why people
if you let's just go into the video all right the
first quote that he has here I think this is the
one from the Josh Horowitz show the podcast guy
who gets all the greatest interviews in the world
he says you look at Thor one and two they were
quite similar he smoking this Thor Cadence told
time Ragnarok and love and thunder are similar
I think it's about Reinventing it and obviously
being asked about if he would come back for Thor
I've had such a unique opportunity with infinity
war and end game to do very drastic things with
the character I enjoy that I like keeping bit of
people on their toes you're an Italian it keeps
me on my toes it keeps me invested I've said this
before but when it becomes too familiar I think
there's a risk in getting lazy then because I
know what I'm doing I don't know if I'm even
invited back but if I was I think would have
to be a drastically different version in tone
everything just for my own sanity he laughs Thor
lost his mind that last one he's gotta figure it
out now so yeah immediately the main thing you
might be hearing people talking about is he's
saying drastic changes drastic changes and then
when he elaborates on the quote you know what's
saying like tone and everything like okay yeah
it does sound like it went like progressively
goofier with Thor love and thunder in terms of the
interpretation of Thor so yeah I would liken to
say that he would not want to return for that to
me and I think a lot of people probably feel this
way arguably the best interpretation that had
the perfect Middle Ground of Thor was actually
an Infinity War because he's the God of Thunder
he's a God and he was badass in that movie he was
awesome he was Regal but he was also funny and
he was the right blend and that was immediately
following Thor Ragnarok when they reinvented him
to be more funny and he had the perfect mix not
that he he can't just go back to that because he
wants to do something very different so I don't
know what that different would entail but well
I feel like you could almost use this as the
opportunity to go back and maybe nail some of the
tones that they didn't before because I feel like
with the first two Thor movies they are similar
they are going for a more Shakespearean a more
epic grandiose yeah bring back the blonde eyebrows
that's right cut it short those were going for a
tone that I think the first one at least people
agree kind of hit and the second one people seem
to agree didn't hit quite as well and I feel
like yeah we pivoted to Comedy we discovered
Chris Hemsworth has such a great comedic tone
and timing and I feel like now could be an
interesting time to yeah bring the humor back down
to just aspects of the character and maybe really
nailed that epic quality that Epic Fantasy tone
that they've always wanted to and Go full fantasy
with it you know true I think that's actually a
good call you should hire you to direct I am the
new Kevin just from that people assume that it
doesn't sound like this would be the Taiko YTD
person who direct that drastically different
tone right sure immediately they're like okay
it sounds like he wouldn't want to return
of Taiko ytd's coming back but then here's
the quote that he's not citing Taiko YTD here
uh yet people uh have interpreted it and then
even John and I were like let's just go to Chris
Hemsworth IMDb and see if there's like something
here that we could maybe pinpoint a little bit
because I'm trying to figure it out it could
be actually this director it's time to play
who's he talking about yeah I mean he's got
these repeating experiences with extraction so
it's probably not that director I mean Andrew
Goddard with uh bad times yeah it's the Russo
Brothers uh yeah so here's what this quote is
basically he's saying I'm just the point of my
life where I'm meeting with different directors
and people say oh yeah look he imaginious he mad
while he's a genius he'll Mark great films and I'm
like is that who I want to spend more days with
uh four months five months of shooting there you
got press and possible reshoots and so on and he
went out to praise George Miller because he's uh
in the Mad Max or the furiosa prequel film and
uh he was like we're talking about George Miller
yeah and then when you're hearing stuff
like talking about these eccentricities
and then dealing with someone like this for so
long and when you think of the directors he's
worked with some of the most eccentric with the
most definitive idiosyncrasies would probably
be Taiko YTD Michael man it's got to be Michael
Mass but I never worked with him again I hate
working with this guy too many retakes one and
done Chris that's me because a lot of the films
he's done he's worked with them several times and
it's sort of like the Mad genius and I don't know
he's he's collaborated now uh with taika it looks
like on three things he was on that James and the
Giant Peach and taika and friends thing they seem
like the reporter in the Press was was Grand so I
was like which which director is it where he had
this experience recently with because I can't is
it like and honestly you know not to discuss it's
definitely going to sound this way it like it's
hard to not think is he talking about Tiger Woods
it is it just sounds like he is especially when
you look at the other quote like he's talking
about yeah because it's that thing of you look
at the personality and taika has a big personality
and if you look at the Thor love and thunder press
tour it seemed like he was at least establishing
a tone that didn't rub everybody the right way
that could then suggest that yeah maybe on set
taika has his own atmosphere and it's your job
to kind of adapt to it rather than being like a
full-on collaborative presence or something like
that but then again I don't know it does seem like
in the past they've gotten along famously but it
could also too be something of a middle ground
you know maybe there's a lacking Nuance where
it's like yes maybe he and taika are friends
but maybe taika's style after two of the most
expensive and high production value movies you
know of his career maybe he's yeah realizing I
would rather work with filmmakers who established
a set that is kind and inclusive and a fun place
to spend your time and I mean you know for the
below the line and for the less you know flashy
jobs they often say like one of the best assets
you could have is just being Pleasant on set you
know well it sounds to me like tiger YTD I mean
with regardless of this quote I feel like taco it
like even though he has said he'll return I think
of something along the lines of Chris Hemsworth
uh want some too or something like that but I
imagine that with the way Chris Hemsworth seems to
operate and I love how he's taking this character
of Thor and has become sort of this actor who does
look at the directors he wants to work with you
know he's that leading man status now where he
can go it's this director so I want to work with
him because of this kind of guy he's not a movie
star he's not a movie star though yeah let's not
forget those words and I'm working with Terrence
so I feel like he might be in a position where
he semi chooses who that next director is sure
he has a say and who that next director might be
which would be pretty cool um and I'd be I'd be
down to see who he picks Ron Howard they've worked
together twice already make it happen again that's
the one that's just the Mad genius he's sick
of the director of Men In Black International
that was uh oh my gosh I did Friday and and oh
really and uh gray F Gary gray did a minute black
International that's who he's talking about I
think so crazy ass Gary gray wow in that Authority
though to choose the next director pretty much
like the way some of these headlines make it sound
is that it's uh oh my God like no I have demands
but I don't know it sounds like casual about it
yeah all of Chris Hemsworth news lately has had
that quality where the the headlines are like
oh man Chris is upset oh no wait he's actually
pretty thoughtful about this he's just kind of
Taken life because of Alzheimer's disease yeah
he's like no he's just aware that he can be so
susceptible yeah I gotta be a little cautious and
it also just takes some time for all the dust to
settle I mean Thor 11 Thunder is pretty fresh
so you know we'll see but I feel like too you
know after two installments of taika I don't think
anybody would be heartbroken to see a fresh take
you know he certainly left his Mark and I think
taika's Mark will endure regardless and I think
that it should be like Chris Hemsworth has talked
about that he would want it to be the final one if
he does return and I think it should be the final
one like I think there's a way to close out Chris
Hemsworth's Journey with the character where you
do finalize that Arc and I wouldn't want love
and thunder to be his last performance um I think
it would be I mean obviously probably being like
Secret Wars or some [__] but I feel like for
like a solo Thor film I would love to see that
Arc really come full circle where it does go back
to being more of the Gaga of thunder and where
he reaches a true maturity as a character I think
is is something that we could see that's new yeah
yeah that'd be awesome all right guys well what
do you think about this story leave your thoughts
down below uh be sure to subscribe leave a like
click that Bell and let's end this with a patreon
Brian Perry Brian Brad Perry you've been a
patron of ours for 12 months exactly welcome
to your one year anniversary for being part of our
patreon page not many people get to say they can
do that and uh you're one of the few so thank
you so much for being here for a full year I
hope the year has been rewarding I hope you've
enjoyed what we've had to offer and I just want
to say I just hit my chest way too hard uh thank
you for being a part of of our lives in such a
meaningful way so say this and but I when I
say to the patrons especially their support
means the world I really mean that because uh
you guys are absolutely incredible special to
us and so thank you Brian for being part of
that category let's select a few much love
to you brother and I hope that uh fun times are
happening in Liverpool those are Liverpool [Music]
right
[Music]